[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 voici les titres de ce jeudi 4
mai 2010 est le parti du nouveau
président emmanuel macron présentait ce
jeudi la liste de 450 candidats
étiquetés et premier non dans les
yvelines
à suivre d'ici à l'automne 2010 est la
rd 30 à plaisir et l'encours doit être
entièrement doublés et aménagé sur 3 km
8 ce chantier ambitieux entamé en
janvier 2015 doit permettre à ces taxes
entièrement saturé de fluidifier
considérablement le trafic sans sa
caravane le tour ne serait pas vraiment
le tour il suffit d'être sur le bord de
la route pour comprendre que la caravane
publicitaire et presque le clou du
spectacle du tour de france à quelques
semaines du départ c'est déjà le moment
de préparer les véhicules mais tout de
suite une scène impressionnante ce matin
sur la rd 10 à hauteur de la verrière
deux compagnies de crs des urgentistes
du samu des policiers étaient mobilisés
pour une intervention sur le site de
l'entreprise valeo
une intervention qui n'était en réalité
qu'un exercice un entraînement de
confinement afin de réagir au mieux en
cas d' attaque terroriste
la circulation aux abords du quartier
restait difficile
jusqu'au début de l'après midi deux
hommes neuf femmes vont se lancer dans
la campagne pour les élections
législatives sous la bannière de la
république en marche
parmi eux parmi ceux qui ont été
désignés par dont on retrouve didier
baichère conseiller municipal de
versailles aurore bergé tranche
transfuge du parti les républicains est
élu dans la commune de magny les hameaux
ou encore michel de vaucouleurs issus du
modem avec un mandat municipal à poissy
pour le moment aucun candidat dans la 9e
circonscription
les autres candidats sont issus de la
société civile et du monde associatif
aussi hâtif pardon je vous propose
d'écouter asys françois n'diaye
coordinateur du mouvement dans les
yvelines
nous aurons un maillage et un
accompagnement suffisant pour qu'il soit
intégré dans un groupe et dans une
structure qui soit suffisamment
structurée pour qu'ils
puissent bénéficier de tous toutes les
ressources tous les outils nécessaires
pour un pouvoir faire campagne comme il
faut et par exemple pour ma part dans
les yvelines
je serai là la tête de liste entre
guillemets si on peut appeler ça comme
ça je ne serai pas candidat dans aucune
circonscription mais je serai candidats
dans toutes les circonscriptions pour
accompagner mon candidat justement à ce
que la campagne qu'ils auront à faire
une bonne nouvelle pour les usagers de
la rd 30 à partir de demain les
automobilistes pourront circuler sur une
partie du tronçon la voix sous le
giratoire des gâtines et le pont de la
rue jules régnier est désormais ouverte
une première étape qui marque une grande
avancée dans ce chantier d'envergure
reportage à plaisir de camille lambert
plus de 30 mille véhicules par jour
circuleront désormais sur cette section
de la rd 30 une avancée attendue dans ce
secteur encombré
l'accès à la rn 12 se veut plus facile
et plus fluide coupe comme ça le flux de
circulation de ceux qui empruntent cette
route départementale 30
je rappelle vient de poissy pour aller
vers elancourt donc franchir ou donner
accès à la nationale 12
vous pouvez maintenant avoir un trafic
séparés entre ce que l'on appelle le
trafic de transit et le trafic y est
plutôt plaisir war la rd30 élargie à
deux fois deux voies passe sous le
giratoire des gâtines la circulation
s'effectuera sur une file dans chaque
sens jusqu'à l'achèvement des travaux
sur l'ensemble du tracé une mise en
service prévue pour la fin de la nuit
qui doit bien pour noël 2010 est on aura
terminé les gros ouvrages et la
circulation pourra être donnée aux
véhicules à moteur
pourquoi je fais ce distinguo parce que
arrive deux autres ensembles qui sont
des passerelles pour la circulation
douce parce que vous avez une voie verte
une voie verte et 2 passerelle piétons
et cycles qui permettront le
franchissement de la n12 pour rejoindre
elancourt
fin des travaux prévue pour 2018 à
guyancourt l'agent ce cadre de pôle
emploi organise est aujourd'hui
forum de la professionnalisation et de
l'apprentissage entreprises et centres
de formation pouvait ainsi rencontrer
directement les candidats
près de 120 postes à pourvoir
principalement en apprentissage ou en
contrat de professionnalisation
reportage à devis en cours de nicolas
d'andry et mélinda coria voilà après on
va juger selon votre niveau ou est ce
qu'on peut vous proposer un poste ou pas
comment cibler les bonnes offres sur
internet comment mettre en valeur ses
compétences derrière un écran voilà
quelques-unes des problématiques qui se
posent aux demandeurs d'emploi elles
sont aujourd'hui surmonté grâce à ce
forum et pour mélissa qui recherchent un
cdi depuis un an et demi le premier
entretien de la journée semble déjà être
le bon je cherche vraiment à pouvoir
m'épanouir dans un travail qui me plaît
ce que je faisais de laquelle je fais de
l'accueil depuis un an et demi et c'est
ce qui me plaît réellement
on m'a demandé ce que j'avais fait quel
était mon parcours et ça s'est super
bien passé parce qu'on m'appelle demain
pour un entretien
comme mélissa à près de 500 personnes se
sont rendues au forum organisé par l'
agence pôle emploi de guyancourt
l'occasion pour les candidats d'approché
directement des potentiels employeurs
c'est vrai que nous dans notre quotidien
quand je rencontre les employeurs quand
une sollicite pour diffuser des entend
pas leur trouver des profils
là on a le plus de retour à l'emploi
c'est quand on organise des rencontres
donc que ce soit sous forme de job
dating où ce système de forums côté
employeur une vingtaine d'entreprises et
de centres de formation étaient présents
des buts c'est d'être vraiment
confrontés directement au public
demandeur d'emploi parce que c'est vrai
qu'à un cv c'est pas très parlant
mais on a l'occasion au moins de pouvoir
les voir en direct de discuter avec eux
leur donner des conseils aussi parce que
parfois ils ne savent pas vraiment
rédiger correctement un cv donc on a des
bonnes surprises donc on n'est pas
vraiment pour rencontrer des candidats
prendre rendez vous avec ceux qui
correspondent en tout cas nos pré requis
de recrutement au total près de 120
postes étaient à pourvoir lors de cette
journée un espace dédié à la préparation
de l'entretien d'embauché était
également mise en place
elle fait patienter le public en était
le long des routes depuis 1930
juste avant le passage des coureurs
cyclistes la caravane publicitaire du
tour de france se prépare 170 véhicules
et près de 600 personnes seront
mobilisées pour animer et distribué 14
millions d'objets la création des
véhicules est déjà en préparation comme
dans cet atelier
reportage à bazoches sur guyonne de
michael et demi d'euros bonjour donc bah
bienvenue à la fabrique c'est ici qu'on
prépare le départ du tour de france
transformation de véhicules légers
houchard fabriqué de a à z depuis deux
ans vincent et la vingtaine d'artisans
de cet atelier travail pour la caravane
du tour de france ce qui est magique
c'est que tous les ans et
différents enfin tous les ans en tout
cas il ya des choses différentes
affaires il ya des gros problèmes
techniques on rencontre à résoudre moi
ça fait partie des choses qui
m'intéresse le plus ce que je préfère
c'est en dehors du fait que je sais que
c'est pouvoir dire à mon client oui on
peut faire n'importe quoi on peut faire
tout ce que vous voulez et quand le
client m'apporte un projet où je me dis
hou là comment je vais faire
en fait c'est ces projets là les plus
intéressants on récupère le décor on le
bricoles pour voir comment on passe la
capote
on conçoit toute la structure pour le
fixer sur le châssis 23 véhicules de 4
marques sont en train d'être créée t ils
seront livrés 4 à 5 jours avant le grand
départ les chantiers pour la caravane du
tour c'est à peu près 20% du chiffre
d'affaires
le tour de france c'est un vrai cas
d'école parce que on fabrique vraiment
du dieu en norme du sur mesure
et puis dans un cadre un peu festif
parce que le tour voilà c'est un côté
magique
les contraintes sont le cahier des
charges de l'organisateur du tour le
code de la route
et puis et puis les contraintes de la
marque bien entendu
rendez vous le samedi 1er juillet à
düsseldorf pour le départ du 100 4e tour
de france plus de 10 millions de
spectateurs devrait voir passer les
créations de la fabrique
après les cours les essais hier 5 lycée
versaillais participer à un tournoi
organisé rien que pour eux par le
rugby-club de versailles toute une
après-midi pour remporter le trophée
conquis l'an dernier par le lycée
saint-jean hull ce reportage à
versailles de mélodies poquet et patrick
jacq dixmude cinq établissements au
départ un seul sacre et à l'arrivée le
rugby-club de versailles organisé hier
sa 2e édition du tournoi des lycées de
versailles c'est d'abord un clin d'oeil
à l'histoire du club de versailles c'est
que le club des centenaires et en 1893
le rugby est né au lycée hoche à
versailles
et si aujourd'hui depuis toujours le
rugby est à versailles et sort des
lycées et donc le slogan à versailles
c'est pas rugby études ses études puis
rugby poule de milliers final un tournoi
de rugby à 7 complet pour désigner le
meilleur lycée de la ville près de 90
joueurs ont foulé la pelouse du stade de
porchefontaine les petites concurrences
dans on a un peu on a peu mis à
l'épreuve mais disons que c'est pour le
plaisir quoi c'est plutôt pour retrouver
les copains allaient prendre du plaisir
ensemble un tournoi pour transmettre les
valeurs du rugby créer de nouvelles
équipes et pourquoi pas se faire repérer
par les entraîneurs du club
connaissez-vous bien votre département
pour le vérifier il ya désormais un
livre yvelines cent lieues pour les
curieux l'ouvragé sorti le 13 avril
dernier son auteur christelle pigeon
nous emmène à la découverte de lieux
insolites
reportage à la biscuiterie de varennes
de haussmann van der veen la biscuiterie
maison la varenne situé à versailles est
l'un des cent lieux choisis par
christelle pigeons sa particularité la
responsable a repris les recettes du
chef de cuisine qui officiait sous louis
xiv adaptés à la clientèle d'aujourd'hui
ce lieu plein de poésie mélange
gastronomie et histoire la dame qui
dirige cette biscuiterie confierez il ya
le corner qui était passionné d'histoire
et en fait elle a pris les recettes de
cuisine du cuisinier la marraine qui
officiait sous louis xiv et les héros
tragiques du vieux françois pour
proposer aujourd'hui aux clients de
manger les mêmes gâteau que manger louis
xiv louis 15 pour lui celle dont je
trouvais le concept vraiment original et
assez insolite et pour trouver ces lieux
insolites l'auteur a travaillé pendant
un an grâce au bouche à oreille et aux
offices de tourisme le livre de 160
pages est illustré de 300 photos et de
permettre au lecteur de découvrir les
richesses du territoire où qu'ils soient
curieux faut qu'ils aient pas peur
d'aller aussi bien limité le parc aux
étoiles où on parle que d'astrologie que
le musée des petits trains où il ya ce
n'est que pour les passionnés de petit
train
enfin voilà il ya j'ai essayé de mettre
des choses déjà quitté de temps tout le
département
parce que comme je disais département
est grand et en même temps qu'ils
puissent plaire à tout le monde
les familles les amoureux les gens qui
aiment la littérature là
yveline cent lieues pour les curieux est
à découvrir aux éditions bonneton une
séance de dédicaces est organisée samedi
13 mai à la maison de la presse au
vésinet c'est la fin de ce set merci de
nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver sur tv fil 78 points
comme ou l'application tv fil 78 bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]